es ist wirklich etwas verrückt negative
masse etwas wiegt nicht zehn gramm
sondern - 10 gramm
wie bitte aber genau das haben forscher
jetzt gemacht sie haben atome mit
negativer masse geschaffen wie was warum
es echt ziemlich rätselhaft ich hoffe
dass wir jetzt den schleier etwas lüften
können bei klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
was haben die da bitteschön gemacht wir
haben ja schon mal über das
bose-einstein-kondensat berichtet es
wurde letztes jahr erstmalig im weltraum
hergestellt wenn man atome eines glases
annähernd auf den absoluten nullpunkt
von minus 273 15 grad celsius
heruntergekühlt
dann befinden sie sich in einen extremen
aggregatzustand sie sind ein
bose-einstein-kondensat das besondere
daran ist dass sich diese atome wie ein
einziges atom verhalten und dieser
atomkomplex schwingt dann wellenartig im
gleichtakt das bedeutet dass man in
dieser atomwolke kein einzelnes atom
mehr ausmachen kann
sie sind eins geworden und jetzt haben
forscher mit diesem kondensat etwas
ziemlich verrücktes angestellt und damit
die welt der physik auf den kopf
gestellt obwohl eigentlich nicht der
negative masse ist in der konten physik
theoretisch möglich doch das ist jetzt
auch praktisch der fall peter engels und
sein team an der washington state
university haben etwas wirklich
außergewöhnliches hinbekommen sie haben
atomen eine negative masse verlieren
dazu haben sie ein
bose-einstein-kondensat erzeugt
wichtiges vorwissen jedes teilchen hat
einen spin einen drehimpuls der ist je
nach teilchen unterschiedlich und damit
sind wir wirklich bei einem der
kompliziertesten themen in der physik
nicht von ungefähr habe ich nie ein
video über den kreisel gemacht aber das
kommt vielleicht demnächst schauen wir
mal
die physiker haben also dieses
bose-einstein-kondensat aus rubidium
atome polt und danach mit lasern
durchgeschüttelt und ihren spin geändert
durch den effekt der spin bahn kopplung
passierte das absolut verblüffende die
rubidium atome verhielten sich jetzt so
als hätten sie eine negative masse der
effekt war verblüffend das
bose-einstein-kondensat befindet sich in
einer falle wird sie geöffnet breitet es
sich aus jetzt war genau das gegenteil
der fall
zitat wenn wir die schubsen
beschleunigten sie rückwärts so der co
autor michael forbes 2 wenn jetzt hier
noch einiges unklar bleibt aber das ist
wirklich mega kompliziert ich versuche
es bald in einem weiteren video mal
verständlich zu erklären wenn er es und
alle anderen videos nicht verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir genau hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht mehr ein
auf die glocke zu geben und hier geht es
zu den besten tipps und videos und
sonst bis dann bleibt dran